welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and this is a breakdown of Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles Mutant Mayhem the
turtles are back they're fully animated
and for the first time their voice by
actual teenagers as a kid who grew up
playing with Ninja Turtles toys with
eating Ninja Turtles ice cream go and
hang out with the Ninja Turtles at
Disney's MGM Studios and giving Raph the
biggest hug a four-year-old could give I
love this movie
this movie so many Easter eggs and
animation details so I'm gonna break it
all down and hey we're on YouTube and Mr
Beast freaking cameos in this movie so I
think we're just obligated to break it
down and talk about it okay the opening
shot is of a New York city sewer manhole
cover but we expect to be the home of
the Turtles and Splinter but not yet
we're getting a new origin story that we
see right here Cydia utram is voiced by
Maya Rudolph sending out a strike force
to reclaim proprietary Tech of tcri the
Techno Cosmic Research Institute now the
tcri is an organization that has existed
many iterations of the Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles and mini Turtles universes
the ultrams are an alien race that Krang
is a part of you know crying but as far
as we know in this film Cynthia is just
a human with an alien last name though
the strike voice is rolling with some
serious Tech their weapons neutralize
mutants which comes back into play in
the Final Act of the movie that's the
only way they're able to defeat super
duper plug so this Strike team is after
Baxter Stockman voiced by Giancarlo
Esposito in his research and ooze
samples he used to create mutants in
comics in a previous iteration Stockman
is kind of a crazy easy scientists who
creates the Mausers which are
chicken-shaped robots starkman is also
mutated into a large fly the design of
him here actually kind of nods to that
as does his surrogate fly baby's son
becomes Superfly in this movie and
another turtle's iteration he implants
his brain into a giant robot but here
Stockman tells his fly baby that they
can be a family and that he can finally
create a family and feel like he belongs
using his mutagen there are test tubes
featuring baby animal versions of the
mutants that we will meet later
thankfully all baby animals here are the
same size they can fit in test tubes but
we see gestating pretty much all them
there's a future Genghis frog a future
Leatherhead and a future Bebop we
actually see sketches of the mutated
Rhino that will become Rocksteady
warthog that becomes Bebop a gator that
becomes Leatherhead and a manta ray that
will become Ray Flay and you can
actually see a green Post-It note where
Stockman was already planning to make
bebop's iconic glasses mutant Mayhem
just looks so different from any other
animated movie I've ever seen and that's
because writer director Jeff Rowe built
on the animation style of Spider-Man
into the spider-verse and he said that
he wanted to make the art look
intentionally unrefined he said quote we
decided we wanted this movie to look
exactly like a concept artwork and we we
want the concept artwork to feel
distinctly human and not computer
generated yes good man and he said and
that means sketchy and imperfect and
misshapen and reminiscent of the way you
draw when you're a child or a teenager
and your passion and your enthusiasm for
making art hasn't been dimmed by formal
art training it's the kind of drawing
you do before you have that voice in
your head that says don't do that that's
not how you draw and so we see that with
Stockman's scribbly hair and his beard a
hairstyle that Superfly will later take
on which is adorable and Stockman's
Twitchy two-dimensional eyes and in many
shots the background services that would
have writing on them are just scribbles
for a movie that really celebrates the
teenage and the mutant aspects of TMNT
that choice just works so well so
Stockman's babyfly does an impressive
job fighting back and even manages to
scratch up the face of spider this is
the head of the strike force who later
loses an eye but Stockman is killed in
an explosion and some of that mutant gin
drips down in the sewer Baxter's fly Sun
manages to escape with his baby mutant
siblings as we cut to 15 years later we
see Leo dripping on his blue mask being
the most disciplined with his ninja
training dining with a staff half Mikey
with his nunchucks and wrath licks his
side why does he do this well maybe some
pizza grease is left on it because we
see later when he stabs the bread he
uses these to snatch food all the time
graph is also the one Turtle missing a
tooth I thought that might be because
he's just always the first to rumble but
we see even as a baby he has that
missing tooth as well it just never
really grew in now when we first see
these Turtles they have way more intense
white eye design similar to how they
were when they were first conceived by
Kevin Eastman back in 1984 but as soon
as we learned their mission is to get
Gogurt and other groceries suddenly
their eyes have pupils making them seem
like boyish teenagers we also see how
the Moon is now way dimmer and more
realistically massed by the city's Haze
and light pollution Leonardo in this
movie is voiced by Nicholas Cantu Micah
Abby is Donatello Shimon Brown Jr is the
voice of Michelangelo and Brady noon is
wrath Jeff Rowe has said that he let the
tape roll between the takes so you'd get
that authenticity of them talking over
each other he said quote just letting
them talk about YouTube videos that they
saw and try to make each other laugh and
we just took so much of that and put it
in the film and again it is Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles and the teenage
Vibes of it is part of what makes it so
great and God I hope that some of those
kids might have seen some of my YouTube
videos that would make my day also I
just like the details that Donnie has
glasses and Mikey has braces don't think
that hard about whatever optometrist or
orthodontist they went to for these I
think they're just little character
design details that make them true
teenagers so they all teased Leo for
making his voice deep like Batman that's
one of many pop culture references we
get in this movie The Turtles actually
did team up with Batman in an animated
film Batman versus the Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles and they have crossed
paths with Batman in the Injustice video
game series though I think here it's
just assumed that Batman is a character
that they see in TV shows and movies and
comic books same with the references to
Avengers in game in the MCU it's just
they watch MCU movies in this world the
turtles use their stealth and weapons
training to steal groceries and we
learned about a series of ice evolving
Superfly rap Mikey and Donnie convinced
Leo to let them stay up for an outdoor
movie screening of Ferris Bueller's Day
Off which is a Paramount movie of course
like this is it's pretty ironic that all
they want is a high school life that
they think Ferris Bueller has when
Ferris Bueller wanted to skip school he
wanted to leave high school they just
want to go to high school Splinter
voiced by Jackie chance Goldson for
being late and Leo confesses that they
stayed out movie and Splinter tells
Mikey not to use rat in a negative way
as in Rat someone out and Splinter again
recounts their origin story briefly we
see a movie truck with a triceraton on
it triceratons are an alien race from
TMNT lore who look like
anthropomorphized triceratopsis Splinter
explains how he found them as maybe
Turtles covered in the Ooze saying
because I was older I became an older
rat you guys are babies so you stay baby
turtle creatures if you think about that
it could make more sense then I just
couldn't help but laugh at this because
of course it doesn't make sense and I
just love the design of younger Splinter
as a dad with a mustache and the Jerry
curl just a sweet Papa he takes them to
Times Square hoping for the best seeing
the bright LED Billboards even a
McDonald's do it closely though it's not
a classic golden arches it's just kind
of a golden squiggle there is a janky
looking SpongeBob SquarePants which of
course another Nickelodeon property this
peaceful moment of bliss is broken by
the public freaking out of the sight of
a giant rat one bystander who tries to
see if Splinter is actually a man in
costume his voice by Mr Beast AKA Jimmy
Donaldson He's listed in the credits As
Time Square guy he says it's real I
touched it after the public turns
against splinter he vows keep the
turtles from getting hurt by humans by
unlocking the ancient secrets of
ninjutsu through Carrie Lee's guide to
self-defense which is a real
self-defense video made in 1988. they
also watch easy bow staff tricks for
beginners a YouTube video made by black
belt scenery that you can watch for
yourself if you want also just some
classic martial arts movies like one of
them that we see in this montage is
snake and Eagle's Shadow which is an
early Jackie Chan movie that's
considered the movie that made him
famous throughout this we see them
getting their iconic weapons including
Don's bow staff which eventually adorn
with stickers to show off his
personality including a Gojo sticker
from the anime Jiu Jitsu Kaizen thank
you to betterhelp for sponsoring this
video watching stuff frame by frame is
great but it can also be really
rewarding to zoom out and look at things
like story pasting and character
development for a movie you can just let
it play out but when you're the target
of analysis it's better to get some help
from betterhelp regardless if you have a
clinical mental health issue like
depression or anxiety or if you're just
going through a hard time therapy can
give you some tools to approach your
life in a very different way with better
help you can tap into a network of over
30 000 licenses and experienced
therapists who can help you with a wide
range of issues it's easy to sign up and
get matched with a therapist there's a
link in my description it's
betterhelp.com new rockstars to get
started just answer a few questions
about what you're looking for from
therapy and what your preferences are
better help will then match you with a
therapist from their Network that's
right for you if you don't really fit in
with that therapist which is a common
thing with therapy you can easily switch
to a therapist for free without
stressing about insurance or who's in
your network or anything like that you
can always benefit from talking to
somebody and getting things off your
chest so if you're struggling consider
online therapy with better help click
the link in the description or visit
betterhelp.com do rockstars clicking
that link helps support this channel but
it also gets you 10 off your first month
of better help so the turtles get
grounded and among the clutter in the
room we see a Planet Hollywood mug a
Super Soaker on the ground and a Target
board hanging on a pipe with a score
sheet underneath wraps size sticks out
from the underwear drawer Leonardo as a
poster for secret ninja Roaring Tiger on
his bunk which is a Korean martial arts
film from 1982 Donatello has a globe and
stacks of books next to his bed as well
as the model of the Space Shuttle and
the computer monitor with icons on the
desktop that are just a complete mess I
feel you Donnie I don't organize my
desktop either Superfly and his goons
steal more equipment and bring it back
to the beach oil tanker from tcri but at
tcri HQ we see that it has been
5745 days since the last successful
mutation which if you do your math that
would mean it has been 15 years and 270
days which is about the time Stockman
was killed we can also see the failed
mutation jars on the wall and spider now
rocks an eye patch Neutron wants to use
trackers on the equipment to get
Superfly found so the turtles are doing
some weapons practice on the roof with
watermelons calling out that Mikey said
looks like Stewie had a baby with Hey
Arnold Hey Arnold a Gore is another
reference to a Nickelodeon property and
while throwing their ninja stars they
hit April O'Neil in the helmet and while
yelling at them she gets her scooter
stolen Turtles give Chase and leads him
to this chop shop and they fight these
guys at The Chop Shop their first real
fight with criminals who confused them
for little Shreks and Geico geckos they
bump their head into the car radio that
plays the Ninja app from Vanilla Ice go
ninjas go ninjas go of course from
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles 2 the
Secret of the Ooze from 1991 director
Jeff Rose said that this was his
favorite Easter egg was suggested by
Seth Rogen and I very much agree I love
this April is voiced by Ayo adibiri who
is so good in the bear and she gets to
know the turtles over Pizza under a neon
sign that says the layered a reference
to Teenage Ninja Turtles co-creator
Peter Laird April is a high school
journalist tracking supervised crimes
and the turtles devise a plan to stop
Superfly and allow April who they list
in their phone as April parentheses
human to tell her story to get the
humans to accept them they compare it to
how Hulk was able to get decided to
accept him by saving the day and Mikey
remind us all of Mark ruffalo's
improvising skills in Avengers endgame
setting up his specific love of improv
in this movie I also love how in Donny's
imagination of their plan to win the
love of humans the turtles are again
drawn with white eyes looking like
heaven Eastman's art of them April's
journalist mind is in overdrive as we
see her notebook some of the questions
she has about the turtles including can
you carry salmonella or other diseases
have you caught covid like can you get
sick are you the source of coven are the
weapons from hot top pawn shop self-made
how many people has the red bandana
Turtle stab does he need therapy
unrelated how much toilet paper is too
much for the sewer to handle can you be
good and just if I've seen you be ninjas
will you have to kill me now do you have
superhuman or turtle strength what do
you eat besides pizza are there any
pizza spots you recommend does your
blood have acid-like properties what's
your lifespan to your Shell's molt does
your rat dad molt do you have ears and
we also see on the margins that she's
been trying to work out their hands and
their number of fingers April takes them
to her High School Eastman High which is
a not two turtles co-creator Kevin
Eastman the turtles love
with an attack on Titan drawing on it
for shadowing the battle tactic they use
in the third act and Mikey signs up for
improv comedy team tryouts and we
confirm the turtles do not have last
names and see the graffiti on her locker
April has to reveal her humiliation as
puke girl the flashback showing her
puking Nickelodeon slime colored vomit
all over the set as we feel the rain on
our skin it's just so sad because you'll
notice in the cue cards they put Hearts
over the eyes in April O'Neil then this
awesome Montage set to No Diggity the
turtles take down the crime families
including short Sharon bald Bronson to
batam normal neat and bad Bernie
director jeffrow confirmed that this
sequence was inspired by the quarter
fight scene in old boy they acquire the
clothes they'll later wear at the end of
the movie to their first day of school
including Don's purple JoJo hoodie Leo
wears a preppy blue polo tucked into
khakis like his own version of a school
uniform and by the way the shirt I am
wearing is a special collaboration
between new rock stars and kind of fit
kind of fat they're a really fun body
inclusive clothing brand whose products
celebrate working out and eating great
food check out the muscle mutant meal
prep shirt on their side kind of fit
kind of fat.com when it drops in a few
weeks Don gets a call from Splinter and
his ringtone is an 8-bit version of
butter by BTS
something his brothers will later try to
sue them with when they're getting
milked by the way I love all Splinter
spheres of them getting milked is
exactly what happens to them always
listen to your dad's Splinter surprises
them with a human World restaurant
experience with some Pizza Hut pizzas
complete with the three Chris's Chris
Evans Chris Pratt and Chris Pine but of
course Chris Pine is the only one who's
in his character costume Captain Kirk
from Star Trek which is another
Paramount Property they meet Superfly
who's voiced by Ice Cube Bebop is voiced
by Seth Rogen who also co-wrote and
produces film Rocksteady voiced by John
Cena wing nut voiced by Natasha dimitrio
Ray filet voiced by post Malone which is
why he sings
[Music]
leatherheads voiced by Rose Byrne Mondo
Gekko voiced by Paul Rudd who sat right
next to the Hulk in that scene in
Avengers end game Genghis frog voiced by
Hannibal Burris and scumbug who's voiced
by Alex Hirsch an animator and creator
of Gravity Falls and worked with a lot
of these animators on Mitchell's vs
machines superfly's big plan is to
mutate all animals on Earth and make
them the dominant species while killing
and subjugating humans and humiliating
them so the turtles try to steal the
last piece of the device from Superfly
and his crew as born on Blondes what's
Up transitions into the 2006 YouTube
meme favorite
hey you know the one that He-Man sings
oh my God
during the struggle Superfly quotes
rapper Ice teas six in the morning by
saying six in the morning police at my
door and he gets away with the device
utram and tcri makes Splinter's fears a
reality and they milk the turtles for
their blood despite them not having
nipples and the boys sing some BTS to
calm Donnie April shows up with Splinter
who kicks some major ass after they call
him Ratatouille he utilizes each of the
turtle's weapons and even does a Neo
running on the agent Smith clones from
Matrix Reloaded move using Donny's stats
the turtles convince the other mutants
to turn on Superfly and everyone's on
the same team the superfly still
activates the device he quotes The OJ's
song backstabber saying they smile in a
new face all the time they want to take
your place and the Machine goes into the
river Superfly super mutates into Super
Duper fly a mutant Kaiju composed of bug
eyes mandibles a whale mouth a whole
elephant's head with tusks giraffes
octopus tentacles on the face and head a
crab claw for his right hand and his
hand is made of three narwhals attached
to an arm that's an amalgamation of
animals not to forget the foot made out
of a bunch of Horses The battle is
pretty tough but the turtles lean on
their individual strengths and I like
how specifically we can hear them
mention yes and when they come up with
their battle plan yes and being the
central tenant and philosophy of
improvisation April overcomes her fear
of appearing on camera just to control
the media narrative around the turtles
make it clear that they are the heroes
the turtles commandeer a pizza delivery
van making reference to the Turtle van
the toy version shot Pizza discs and I
totally had this thing Donny pitches a
plan based on Attack on Titan to attack
the Giant's weak spot in the back of his
neck Splinter is knocked to the ground
and as some New Yorkers approach him he
worries that he'll be attacked again
just like in Times Square but this time
a friendly man lends a hand and asks if
he's okay and this is actually a voice
Cameo by Turtles co-creator Kevin
Eastman the turtles mutants and New
Yorkers band together to demutate the
superfly and we totally got vibes from
the first Spider-Man movie
one of us you mess with all of us a news
reporter refers to them as hero Turtles
which is interesting because in the UK
the series was known as Teenage Mutant
hero Turtles because the word ninja was
deemed to have connotations too violent
for kids so the meetings all move into
the sewer with Splinter who is now
dating scumbug calling back his lifelong
friendship with that poor cockroach who
got stomped when he was still just a
normal rat the turtles are heroes they
get to go to high school and again Donny
wears this hoodie with the logo the
anime JoJo's Bizarre Adventure and
Mikey's shirt is very reminiscent of the
Hawaiian Tourist action figure version
of him from 1992 another toy that I had
and April's Locker has gone from April
o' puke to April o hero and has credit's
role they include all the different
animation styles from the different
iterations of the animated turtle shows
and movies and then we get this
mid-credits scene Donnie has found his
click Raph has letting some rage out on
wrestling Mikey is taking improv though
he says no but you should be saying yes
and and Leo in April research tcri which
is vanished Without a Trace said the
utram is still monitoring the turtles
and she's captured a demutated Superfly
she decides his time to call in the big
guns and we see the silhouette of who
else could it be the Shredder the
turtle's most iconic villain and the one
that has a long history with the
ultramalians and the lore who often
provide Shredder with his alien
technology it's never confirmed that
Cynthia was human in this movie and her
character design did invoke some of the
utram species so we will have to wait
and see if we learn more about her
origin hey a huge thanks to Brandon
Barrack Eric Francisco Gina eppolito and
Jordan Morris for researching and
writing this breakdown please subscribe
to all three of the channels in the new
rockstars Network follow me on social
platforms at eavos thanks for watching
and I'll see you next time bye everybody
[Music]
foreign